[Music]
so I'm gonna start riding on you again
and I'm gonna write this down now
because you should write down wishes to
make them come true hey youtubers it's
Charlie this week on Walking Dead we
found out what happened to the rest of
the prison including the rest of the
governors people one major character
came back in a super surprised moment
and we got a teaser for the next area
that they're all making their way to
quick shout-out to my weekly giveaway if
you're finding me for the first time
each week in my Walking Dead review
videos I pick one random subscriber from
the comments to give a $20 Amazon gift
card to I announce the winner in the Q&A
videos I do associate it with this on
Monday nights all you have to do is be a
subscriber and leave a comment but if
you have a specific question that you
want me to include in that Q&A video
just write it in the comments careful
for spoilers from episode ten if you
haven't seen it yet but I'm gonna start
with my top five moments and then I'll
do my review so number five Beth and
Darryl's extended camping trip their
whole extended scene was a lot of fun
comic book readers will remember that
for a brief moment they did hook up but
seeing is the show messes with a lot of
those minor details I'm not expecting a
lot to happen there even Darryl's
previous relationship with Carol kind of
got pushed to the side just a little bit
kooky number 4 Tyreese reveals that he
has baby Judith
this was a huge WTF moment everyone had
been wondering what happened to that car
seat did baby Judith get eaten did
someone grab her we finally found out I
was so happy and so relieved everybody
give each other a giant high-five we can
all breathe a sigh of relief now baby
Judith is not dead number three Maggie
loses her [ __ ] looking for Glenn there
are so many tumblr gifs right now of
Maggie going crazy and after this
episode there will be several new ones I
can only imagine what their children
will end up being like whenever they
grow up someday I feel like that's a bit
of a spoiler though for my prediction
that they'll both survive the season but
if one of them does have to go I think
Maggie will be the one lauren cohan does
such an amazing job of selling anguish
and desperation though I would hate to
see her leave the show this season they
did try to keep faking us out making us
think that Glenn was on the bus but
because we had seen the teaser from last
week that moment had essentially been
spoiled so it did take me out of the
scene just a little bit but lauren cohan
was so amazing number two Abraham's
group to the rescue took him long enough
we knew that they were coming at the end
of last year at the characters that is
but we didn't know which episode they
buin or which group would run into them
I think that it's great that it was Tara
obviously Glenn is out cold so he'll
meet them later but this gives Tara the
opportunity to start fresh
she was so hung up on the idea of
redemption and Glen did this really
amazing job of explaining the difference
between wants and needs given the fact
that they need to find the rest of the
survivors pronto I do think that her
story for the rest of the season will be
all about redemption though I am looking
forward to her getting some really
awesome moments and my number one moment
no surprise here Carol appears out of
nowhere with baby Judith Lizzie and mica
there were a lot of WTF moments but
Carol coming back this early and pulling
off such a big save was definitely my
favorite
I think of Carol's interest as being
like a reverse Batman like instead of
disappearing whenever you turn around
she just magically appears I love that
look on her face whenever she saw that
Tyrese recognized that she was there she
doesn't know whether or not he knows
about Karen I'm expecting him to find
out soon but it seems like for now all
will be well between them
okay so honorable mentioned in this
episode goes to Lizzie and mica normally
I do not like children on intense drama
shows like Walking Dead but they were
amazing Lizzie is so hardcore now that
watching her try to fill Carol shoes was
a lot of fun I feel like a lot of her
maturation happened off screen we really
only saw her getting yelled at by Carol
and then during the prison plague she
just kind of tuned everything out and
went dead inside and then cut to the
prison attack where she's gunning people
down in cold blood without a second
thought I can only imagine what her
teenagers are gonna be like I hope that
the show goes on that long and she stays
on the show but now it's your turn let
me know what was your favorite moment
from the episode and do you think that
Abraham's group will head for the
sanctuary too because it seems like
everyone else is headed there just to
reiterate the new characters are Abraham
Rosita and Eugene I cannot wait to see
what dynamic they add to the show as
well as how the other characters
interact with them right now it's really
just tearing Glenn overall I really
liked the episode it was another huge
shift from the Carl Griffin episode last
week I gave that episode an A and I feel
like I have to give this episode at
least an a-minus the only issue and
using the entire ensemble is is that you
don't get as many chances to develop
characters Glenn is definitely the
exception this time though he's the
character that you're really used to
thinking of as a loner so why wouldn't
he show up alone after the prison fight
I loved that he helped tear out I can't
wait to see how she tries to redeem
herself for the rest of this
and she's like the new Lizzy on the show
now small and helpless but on the path
to becoming a badass I also thought the
way they constructed the story was a lot
of fun all the different groups started
out from the same moment in time and
things just branched out from there each
of their stories branched out separately
that's why we kept seeing the same
locations during different periods of
time I definitely want that sign for my
room though warning hitchhikers may be
escaping inmates like I said I'm
announcing this week's giveaway winner
in my Q&A video tomorrow night be sure
to subscribe to get that right now click
here for last week's Walking Dead
episode and click here for my latest
game of Thrones trailer breakdown they
just posted a new video and there are
dragons everywhere thank you so much you
guys I'll see you tomorrow high fives